Hey guys.
Welcome back.
Today we're going to do a fun
problem that will test your
knowledge of the law
of total variance.
And in the process, we'll also
get more practice dealing with
joint PDFs and computing
conditional expectations and
conditional variances.
So in this problem, we are given
a joint PDF for x and y.
So we're told that x and y can
take on the following values
in the shape of this
parallelogram, which I've drawn.
And moreover, that x and y are
uniformly distributed.
So the joint PDF is just flat
over this parallelogram.
And because the parallelogram
has an area of 1, the height
of the PDF must also be 1 so
that the PDF integrates to 1.
OK.
And then we are asked
to compute the
variance of x plus y.
So you can think of x plus y as
a new random variable whose
variance we want to compute.
And moreover, we're told we
should compute this variance
by using something called the
law of total variance.
So from lecture, you should
remember or you should recall
that the law of total variance
can be written
in these two ways.
And the reason why there's two
different forms for this case
is because the formula
always has you
conditioning on something.
Here we condition on x, here
we condition on y.
And for this problem, the
logical choice you have for
what to condition
on is x or y.
So again, we have this option.
And my claim is that we
should condition on x.
And the reason has to do with
the geometry of this diagram.
So notice that if you freeze an
x and then you sort of vary
x, the width of this
parallelogram stays constant.
However, if you condition on y
and look at the width this
way, you see that the width
of the slices you get by
conditioning vary with y.
So to make our lives easier,
we're going to condition on x.
And I'm going to erase this
bottom one, because
we're not using it.
So this really can seem quite
intimidating, because we have
nested variances and
expectations going on, but
we'll just take it slowly
step by step.
So first, I want to focus
on this term--
the conditional expectation of
x plus y conditioned on x.
So coming back over to this
picture, if you fix an
arbitrary x in the interval,
0 to 1, we're restricting
ourselves to this universe.
So y can only vary between this
point and this point.
Now, I've already written down
here that the formula for this
line is given by y
is equal to x.
And the formula for this
line is given by y is
equal to x plus 1.
So in particular, when we
condition on x, we know that y
varies between x and x plus 1.
But we actually know
more than that.
We know that in the
unconditional universe, x and
y were uniformly distributed.
So it follows that in the
conditional universe, y should
also be uniformly distributed,
because conditioning doesn't
change the relative frequency
of outcomes.
So that reasoning means that
we can draw the conditional
PDF of y conditioned
on x as this.
We said it varies between
x and x plus 1.
And we also said that it's
uniform, which means that it
must have a height of 1.
So this is py given
x, y given x.
Now, you might be concerned,
because, well, we're trying to
compute the expectation of
x plus y and this is the
conditional PDF of y, not of the
random variable, x plus y.
But I claim that we're OK, this
is still useful, because
if we're conditioning
on x, this x
just acts as a constant.
It's not really going to change
anything except shift
the expectation of y
by an amount of x.
So what I'm saying in math terms
is that this is actually
just x plus the expectation
of y given x.
And now our conditional
PDF comes into play.
Conditioned on x, this
is the PDF of y.
And because it's uniformly
distributed and because
expectation acts like center
of mass, we know that the
expectation should be
the midpoint, right?
And so to compute this point, we
simply take the average of
the endpoints, x plus 1 plus
x over 2, which gives us
2x plus 1 over 2.
So plugging this back up here,
we get 2x/2 plus 2x plus 1
over 2, which is 4x plus 1
over 2, or 2x plus 1/2.
OK.
So now I want to look at the
next term, the next inner
term, which is this guy.
So this computation is
going to be very
similar in nature, actually.
So we already discussed
that the joint--
sorry, not the joint, the
conditional PDF of y given x
is this guy.
So the variance of x plus y
conditioned on x, we sort of
have a similar phenomenon
occurring.
x now in this conditional
world just acts like a
constant that shifts the PDF but
doesn't change the width
of the distribution at all.
So this is actually just equal
to the variance of y given x,
because constants don't
affect the variance.
And now we can look at this
conditional PDF to figure out
what this is.
So we're going to take a quick
tangent over here, and I'm
just going to remind you guys
that we have a formula for
computing the variance of a
random variable when it's
uniformly distributed between
two endpoints.
So say we have a random variable
whose PDF looks
something like this.
Let's call it, let's say, w.
This is pww.
We have a formula that says
variance of w is equal to b
minus a squared over 12.
So we can apply that
formula over here.
b is x plus 1, a is x.
So b minus a squared over
12 is just 1/12.
So we get 1/12.
So we're making good progress,
because we have this inner
quantity and this
inner quantity.
So now all we need to do is take
the outer variance and
the outer expectation.
So writing this all down, we
get variance of x plus y is
equal to variance of this guy,
2x plus 1/2 plus the
expectation of 1/12.
So this term is quite simple.
We know that the expectation of
a constant or of a scalar
is simply that scalar.
So this evaluates to 1/12.
And this one is not
bad either.
So similar to our discussion up
here, we know constants do
not affect variance.
You know they shift your
distribution, they don't
change the variance.
So we can ignore the 1/2.
This scaling factor
of 2, however,
will change the variance.
But we know how to handle
this already
from previous lectures.
We know that you can just take
out this scalar scaling factor
as long as we square it.
So this becomes 2 squared,
or 4 times the
variance of x plus 1/12.
And now to compute the variance
of x, we're going to
use that formula again,
and we're
going to use this picture.
So here we have the joint PDF of
x and y, but really we want
now the PDF of x, so we
can figure out what
the variance is.
So hopefully you remember a
trick we taught you called
marginalization.
To get the PDF of x given
a joint PDF, you simply
marginalize over the
values of y.
So if you freeze x is equal to
0, you get the probability
density line over x by
integrating over this
interval, over y.
So if you integrate over
this strip, you get 1.
If you move x over a little
bit and you integrate over
this strip, you get 1.
This is the argument I was
making earlier that the width
of this interval stays the same,
and hence, the variance
stays the same.
So based on that argument, which
was slightly hand wavy,
let's come over here
and draw it.
We're claiming that the PDF of
x, px of x, looks like this.
It's just uniformly distributed
between 0 and 1.
And if you buy that, then we're
done, we're home free,
because we can apply this
formula, b minus a squared
over 12, gives us
the variance.
So b is 1, a is 0, which
gives variance of
x is equal to 1/12.
So coming back over here, we
get 4 times 1/12 plus 1/12,
which is 5/12.
And that is our answer.
So this problem was
straightforward in the sense
that our task was very clear.
We had to compute this, and we
had to do so by using the law
of total variance.
But we sort of reviewed a lot
of concepts along the way.
We saw how, given a joint
PDF, you marginalize to
get the PDF of x.
We saw how constants don't
change variance.
We got a lot of practice
finding conditional
distributions and computing
conditional
expectations and variances.
And we also saw this trick.
And it might seem like cheating
to memorize formulas,
but there's a few important
ones you should know.
And it will help you sort of
become faster at doing
computations.
And that's important,
especially if you
guys take the exams.
So that's it.
See you next time.